[Music]
the truth is we don't know if North
Korea has the ability to hit the United
States with an intercontinental
ballistic missile if we wanted to shoot
it down the only way we could be
reasonably certain of doing so is to get
it in what we call the boost phase
that's when it's lifting off from North
Korea it's probably impossible for us at
this point to have a certainty of
getting it when it's coming down in the
terminal phase also if we did that we
would forfeit the opportunity to gather
intelligence on just how advanced the
missile program is there's also no
assurance that they'd be shooting it
towards us but they could be shooting it
towards other areas in the Pacific or
Asia what we should probably do is
follow it this time gather as much
intelligence as we can see whether the
program is successful and also see where
they sent it if they do send it towards
us we should make clear that US policy
in the future is to shoot down a North
Korean ballistic missile during the
boost phase regardless of whether it is
loaded with a nuclear warhead or whether
it is aimed towards us that's the only
way to make sure that North Korea knows
were serious to learn more about my take
on the risks threatening Asia's future
peace and prosperity check the links in
the description below also let us know
what other topics you'd like a EEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds